now i know a lot of people do not like
their belly fat it doesn't look good it
gets in the way but you have to realize
that this belly fat is the tip of the
iceberg there's a lot more going on
behind the scenes okay then that's what
i'm going to talk about so yes it
doesn't look good but let's talk about
what's really happening on the inside of
your body
for you to have a big belly you first
have to have a fatty liver now the
simple version of this is that your
liver becomes fatty because you're
eating too many carbs and the carbs are
being converted into fat in the liver in
other places
but the liver is only a certain size
there's only so much fat that you can
cram in the liver before it starts to
overfill and spill over into other
organs
outside the fat cell that's called
ectopic fat around the organs that's
called visceral fat so when you see
people with a belly you know they have a
fatty liver and all this is coming from
a high carb diet as well as a person
eating many frequent meals you know
having three meals with two snacks that
increases the insulin and insulin is the
storage hormone it will take those
carbohydrates and it turns the carbs
into fat inside your liver and around
the organs now typically what a person
only sees is what's on the outside they
see their belly
but they don't associate any other
problems at least initially i mean their
blood sugars are usually normal why
because the insulin is taking care of it
the insulin comes in there takes it out
of the blood so then we can maintain
normal glucose levels so we really don't
see the high blood sugar situation for
at least a couple decades and we don't
even see the high insulin that's doing
all this conversion because the doctor
never tests your insulin levels if he or
she did they would find it would be very
very high
and by the way there's a great test
called homa ir to detect your insulin
levels and so here we have this
camouflage situation where
the high sugar is being camouflaged by
the insulin and the insulin is working
really hard in the background to store
all this fat and so unless you have an
ultrasound in the liver you're not going
to detect that there is a fatty liver
all you're going to see is you have a
gut and then as the years go on
as the liver becomes fully filled with
fat and now you start developing insulin
resistance so it takes more and more
insulin to lower this blood sugar until
the point where the body finally can no
longer compensate for all the sugar and
then that's where the blood sugar starts
going up you become a pre-diabetic and
then an actual diabetic so the deeper
cause of this insulin resistance is
really a fatty liver because the liver
can no longer function and everything
starts backing up and you can pretty
much summarize the fatty liver to be aka
also known as a high carb diet and a lot
of people are not connecting the dots
between the other symptoms that this
high
blood glucose and insulin is creating
like fatigue frequent urination
especially at night like sleep apnea
like a weakened immune system like
inflammation in the joints like
arthritis like cravings to sugar or
metabolic syndrome which is high blood
pressure heart disease a fatty liver and
diabetes type 2.
you see all of these things
and a belly fat is coming from the same
thing
high carb diet high blood glucose and
high insulin
so in summary i know your belly fat
doesn't look good but it's just the tip
of the iceberg there's a lot more going
on beneath the scene and so if you're
interested in resolving this i have a
very good solution it's called healthy
keto intermittent fasting
i put a link down below of exactly what
to do to get started
so if you're enjoying my content which i
hope you are
and you're applying this knowledge to
your health
and you have a success i'd really
appreciate you sharing your success
story so click the link down below to my
website where you can upload your
success story so you can help inspire
others